wagt Wagenknecht das wagnispartei
Gründung den Bedarf an links
konservativen denen Populismus nicht
fremd ist den signalisieren viele
Umfragen sondern Wagenknecht selbst
nennt es die Lehrstelle im
Parteiensystem wird sie sie füllen
wollen ein Knackpunkt eine erfolgreiche
Parteigründung ist Knochenarbeit also
werden jetzt Mitstreiterinnen und
Mitstreiter gesucht die Alters haben was
seiner Wagenknecht fehlt Beständigkeit
Berechenbarkeit Genügsamkeit denn die
Fleischtöpfe der Macht sind keineswegs
gesichert er schon Kannibalismus im
linken und ganz rechten Lager nur was
für politische Feinschmecker
kurz vor der Gründung die Folgen einer
Wagenknecht Partei jetzt in der
phönix-runde
Phoenix Runde
herzlich Willkommen bei uns meine Gäste
die wir gestern ist bei uns
politikredakteurin bei der Frankfurter
Allgemeinen Sonntagszeitung astig Lorenz
Professorin an der Universität Leipzig
sie sind dort
haben wir den Lehrstuhl für das
politische System Deutschlands und
Politik in Europa sie passt ja Sebastian
Puschner ist stellvertretender
Chefredakteur und Resort leider Politik
bei der Wochenzeitung der Freitag und
sehr für den Vaillant ist der Akteur im
hauptstadtbüro des Spiegels Puschner
auch wenn vieles darauf hindeutet noch
lässt sich lässt es seiner Wagenknecht
der offen ob sie eine eigene Partei
gründen wird
wie sehen Sie das sollte sie den Schritt
wagen
sollte sie den Schritt wagen ich dachte
jetzt die Fragen wird sie den Schritt
wagen dann hätte ich gesagt ich schätze
mal so auf 70 30 aber wenn Sie fragen
sollte Sie Fragen dann sage ich ja sie
sollte es wagen das kommt aus einer
jahrelangen Beschäftigung mit der Linken
so wie sie ist heraus ich glaube nicht
mehr dass es für diese Parteien
irgendeiner Weise einen Weg gibt auf dem
sie zusammenfinden sich versöhnen und
erneuern fangen starten kann die
Gelegenheiten dafür waren reichlich und
dieses in ihrer Eröffnung angesprochene
diese Lehrstelle im Parteiensystem die
glaube ich die gibt es durchaus von
gestern wie erklären sie sich denn dass
das Thema eine eigenen Partei gegründet
von Sarah werden nicht nun schon so
lange im Raum steht aber die finale
Entscheidung immer noch nicht da ist
worauf Wartet Frau Wagenknecht
eigentlich also ich glaube sie liegt
einfach darauf an maximalen Schaden
anzurichten ehrlicherweise also sonst
würde man doch nicht sich eine Option so
lange offen halten das ist ja ihr Spiel
dass sie da mit den Medien treibt immer
immer wieder Gerüchte nähren dementieren
spekulieren lassen um dann zu sagen ja
ich weiß es noch nicht Ende des Jahres
fällt die Partei während sie ja noch
Mitglied der LINKEN ist also ich glaube
da kann man auch sagen wenn man jetzt
keine besonders beschützerischen Gefühle
für die Linken hat das ist einfach
schlechter Stil also eine destruktive
Haltung weiland hat Frau Wagenknecht wir
erinnern uns ja an das an die
gescheitete aufstehende Bewegung hat sie
denn das Potenzial eine eigene Partei zu
gründen zu führen also Sie haben es ja
in ihrem Intro angesprochen vor Wagen
kenne ich das eine besonders auch
extravertierte Frau es wird dir Nagel
nachgesagt dass sie das was eine Partei
Gründung ja ausmacht nämlich
organisatorische Fähigkeiten zu
entwickeln offenbar in dem Maße nicht
hat und deswegen glaube ich dass sie
auch deswegen zögert weil sie braucht ja
um eine Partei zu gründen einen Unterbau
von Leuten die eher im Schatten agieren
und die eine solche Partei für Sie
organisieren und das wird spannend sein
ob sie dazu in der Lage ist ein Kreis
von Personen zu finden die ihr die
technischen
Fähigkeiten sozusagen abnehmen ich nehme
nur ein Beispiel einen guten
Bundesschatzmeister den braucht man um
die Finanzen zusammenzuhalten sonst
kommt man sehr schnell aufs Glattal das
sind also besonders altruistische
Fähigkeiten gefragt frau Lorenz
angenommen es kommt zu Gründung
was würde denn eine Wagenknecht Partei
für das bestehende parteiengefüge in
Deutschland bedeuten
ich glaube sie wären nicht unbedingt
Mitglieder stark weil die Zahl die Zeit
der mitgliederparteien einfach glaube
ich ohnehin vorbei ist aber trotzdem
kann sie eine kampagnenpartei sein und
große Erfolge feiern in Wahlen die Frage
ist ob man sowas dann hält über längere
Zeit da braucht man dann eben egal ob es
formale Mitglieder sind oder nicht man
braucht Menschen die dann wirklich zu
dieser Partei auch stehen ich sehen
Potenzial dass der AFD was abgegraben
wird ja so ein Potential die er selber
auch kämpft die Protestwähler zu halten
und auch bei der Linken also das sind
glaube ich die Hauptprofiteure was die
Wählerstimmen angeht grundsätzlich ist
es natürlich gut für die anderen
Parteien weil das bedeutet dass dieser
große Gegner AFD geschwächt wird es wird
ja auch immer wieder gemutmaßt dass sie
möglicherweise sogar in nicht Wähler
Lager aktivieren kann das heißt die Zahl
der Wählerinnen und Wähler leitet sich
möglicherweise aus man muss sich aber
trotzdem mit dieser Partei dann die
Wählergunst Teilen wie groß schützen sie
denn das Potenzial der eine
wagenknecht-partei wie soll dann immer
auch heißen wird eine und wer würde sie
vor allen Dingen wählen also es gibt ja
eine Zahl die seitdem immer wieder
herumgeistert das ist eine Zahl die aus
Thüringen stammt
da wird der wagenknackt Knecht Partei
bis zu 25% attestiert nun ist das ein
Spezifikum Thüringen ist ein Spezifikum
es ist ein ostdeutsches Bundesland ich
weiß nicht ob im Westen vor Wagenknecht
wirklich so realisieren kann aber ich
denke schon dass sie Milieus anspricht
in Ostdeutschland zumindest ist meine
These von denen einige Menschen
inhaltlich die AFD aus bestimmten
Gründen mit schlechten Gewissen wählen
und möglicherweise eine sogenannte linke
Partei mit gutem Gewissen wählen würden
die ähnliche Politik Angebote macht
etwas
Kritik an der
Waffenlieferung an die Ukraine soziale
Fragen situationsfragen insofern
durchaus sehe ich ein Potenzial auch
dass die Nichtwähler auszuschöpfen von
denen sich ja einige auch abgewandt
haben von der klassischen Linkspartei
die sich anderen Milieus zugewandt hat
und diese Bindekraft die die Linkspartei
ja viele viele Jahre nach der Wende in
Ostdeutschland hatte nicht in allen
Teilen gleichermaßen aber doch sage ich
mal im norddeutschen Raum in
Brandenburger Raum in Berliner Raum die
ist ja verloren gegangen und darauf
setzt ja auch Frau Wagenknecht die
möchte sie wieder zurückholen für ihre
Partei Neugründung ich glaube es wäre
auf jeden Fall begrüßenswert wenn das
gelänge nicht Fehler wieder an die Ohren
zurückzuholen weil wir haben in
Deutschland schon seit viel zu lange
Zeiten Entwicklungen der gerade in armen
Gegenden wenn sie Stadtteile vergleichen
wenn Sie eine Stadt mit Düsseldorf mit
Gelsenkirchen zum Beispiel
vergleichen bei der letzten Landtagswahl
wo die Wahlbeteiligung wirklich
signifikant unterschiedlich ist und wir
haben auch politikwissenschaftliche
Forschung nach der die Interessen
genauer Menschen sich in politischen
Entscheidungen viel weniger
niederschlagen als es die der sag ich
mal besser verdienenden vermögenden oder
so tun ob das aber gelingt das ist hängt
natürlich von den angesprochenen
organisatorischen Fragen ab ich glaube
Wagenknecht als Person selbst ist dafür
durchaus prädestinierter als viele
andere weil sie von ihrer Rhetorik von
ihrer Sprache her doch so kommuniziert
dass sie vielfach ja verstanden wird wir
sind ja noch beim Thema wie groß könnte
das Wählerpotenzial sein
ich wollte noch mal dazu sagen dass ich
glaube es bleibt trotzdem ein
Top-down-Ansatz möglicherweise wird sie
dann für nicht WLAN gewählt aber
trotzdem kommt das ja gar nicht von
diesen Nichtwählern oder es kommt nicht
von denen die quasi sich als abgehängt
empfinden sondern sie können eigentlich
nur wieder das also ein Paket wählen
oder ablehnen wenn sie sich nicht selber
einbringen das sehe ich jetzt noch nicht
unbedingt das jetzt wirklich ein
massenmobilisiert werden die dann in
diese Partei Strömen und das gestalten
sondern es bleibt ein Angebot einer
stark von einer Person gesteuert wird
was die Mobilisierungsfähigkeit im Osten
angeht das ist sich zwei schneide ich
nicht so eindeutig wenn man wirklich in
die Richtung geht typischer ostdeutsche
Interessen Stichwort auch ähm Haltung
gegenüber Russland dann verliert man
automatisch im Westen ein Potenzial an
Wählerinnen und Wählern denn das ist
glaube ich eine ganz große
kulturunterschied selbst in linken
Kreisen ist glaube ich doch die
Zurückhaltung gegenüber Russland ganz
klar und bei denen die sozialen Proteste
wählen wollen heißt es nicht automatisch
praktisch dass die so pro russisch sich
prostländisch ja also propudding sich
äußern wollen da wird man vieler vor den
Kopf stoßen und insofern ist das wieder
eine Gradwanderung man muss sich
arrangieren wenn man möglichst viele
ansprechen will darf man nicht so eine
klare Russland Strategie fahren wie die
Wagenknecht bis jetzt gemacht
kaum in den Ring steigen 19% habe ich
jetzt irgendwo gelesen bundesweit ist
das eine Größenordnung mit der sie
rechnen kann das wäre ja ein enormer
Einstieg für eine neue gegründete Partei
wäre es aber das sind ja wirklich nur
Umfragen und ich glaube ihr Kollege von
der Leipziger Universität hatte so ganz
hübschen Vergleich dass er sagte na ja
wenn man sich vorhin Supermarkt stellt
und den Leuten sagt es gibt da so ein
ganz neuen Yoga der Mann weiß noch nicht
genau wie er schmeckt können Sie sich
vorstellen den zu kaufen dann würden
vielleicht auch 20% ja sagen also das
sagt er erstmal noch gar nichts über die
realistischen Erfolgsaussichten aus und
ähm ich wundere mich so ein bisschen
dass
hier so klingt zum Teil als würde jetzt
wirklich eine wahnknecht Partei und
unsere Demokratie vor der AFD Wetten
also ganz so einfach scheint mir das
wirklich nicht zu sein gerade wenn wir
über Thüringen sprechen da ist ja der
einzige erfolgreiche Landespolitiker der
Linken Bodo Ramelow den könnte sie ja
zum Sturz bringen das wäre ja wirklich
nicht im Sinne einer linken
ganz kurz noch weil sie jetzt von dem
Joghurt gesprochen haben also offenbar
schmeckt dieser Joghurt auf den Wagen
nicht drauf steht vielleicht auch nicht
so vielen weil das aktuelle
Politbarometer das ZDF hat im August da
gibt es ja dieses Skala von -5 nach plus
fünf für die Leistungen Sympathien von
Politikerinnen und Politikern da schafft
es aber Wagenknecht ganz knapp vor das
Schlusslicht alles Weidel also sie hat
-1,1 ist noch - 2,8 eine Abstand aber
mehr auch nicht ähm bei den Kollegen der
privaten Medien ist es der viert letzte
Platz vor Wissler schon in Wissler der
Linken Parteichefin vor Weidel und Chef
der AFD das ist nicht irgendwie eine
politische irgendwo einem die Herzen und
super Team so zufliegen wenn man diese
Zahlen liest ja absolut nicht und es gab
ja übrigens ganz andere Umfragen die ihr
wiederum nur ein reales Potenzial von
zwei drei Prozent ausmachen und auch die
Linke hat übrigens ein Potenzial von 18
Prozent dass sie nicht ausschöpft also
dass dieses Potenzial da ist ist klar
aber ob eine Wagenknecht das über
vielleicht so ein eine kurzen
Begeisterungssturm der immer mit etwas
Neuem entsteht dann wirklich auch lang
anhaltend ja für sich in Anspruch nehmen
kann würde ich schon stark bezweifeln
aber die Zahlen von Alice Weidel und
Propeller die zeigen ja dass diese
Person die Personen gar nicht so wichtig
sind wenn sie das Gefühl haben sie
wählen jetzt eine bestimmte politische
Richtung bei der AFD sind die Personen
nicht so wichtig gewesen sondern also
ich meine die die unterstützungswerte
die steigen und steigen relativ
unabhängig von diesen Zahlen wie sie
eben gesagt haben
die Zahlen die beispielsweise in Bezug
auf Thüringen
in der Welt jetzt sind auf die ist auf
die es nicht viel zu geben weil man weiß
da hat sich irgendjemand bei einem
Forschungsinstitut ausgedacht wie diese
Partei heißen könnte und vorstellen kann
man sie erst mal vieles man weiß ja auch
nicht mit wem diese Partei dann zum
Beispiel bei den Europawahlen antreten
würde das Sarah Wagenknecht selbst
danach Brüssel geht ist ja ein bisschen
schwer vorstellbar dann wäre sehr hier
von der bundesbühne erstmal wieder weg
also das sind natürlich Projektion
Prognosen diese nett mit den lassen sich
Schlagzeilen machen aber richtig
belastbar sind sie nicht ich kenne eine
politikwissenschaftliche Untersuchung
die ist etwas belastbarer weil die hat
sich nämlich
meinungsforschungszahlen angeschaut
Leute angeschaut die ihr zuneigen und da
sind aber nicht irgendwelche Prozente
diejenigen die rauskommen sondern die
drei Kolleginnen und Kollegen aus der
politikwissenschaftliches untersucht
haben sich angeguckt was sind das für
Leute die sich vorstellen könnten sie zu
wählen und das ist wirklich hoch
interessant weil es sind zum Teil Leute
die mit ihrem linken
wirtschaftspolitischen Kurs gar nicht
viel anfangen können aber eben dieses
gesellschaftspolitisch eher konservative
bedienen und das ist natürlich eine
Sollbruchstelle ob das zusammen geht
zu dem Einwand von Frau Gerster das
möglicherweise ist aber Banken nicht am
Beispiel Thüringen einen erfolgreichen
linken Politiker den einzigen Bodo
ramelo demoliert und am Ende sich nur
Björn höcke ins Fäustchen lacht naja gut
also wenn jetzt diese Prognosen sich so
bewahrheiten würden dann gehen die ja
auch zu kosten klar der AFD das ist ja
sozusagen das was der prognostiziert
worden ist das heißt das hörte davon der
Profiteur dann wäre das ist ja nicht
gesagt und die Situation in Thüringen
ist ja schon jetzt wahnsinnig schwierig
es regiert dort eine
Minderheitsregierung die im Grunde
genommen ja also nicht wirklich regieren
kann und das jetzt Sarah Wagenknecht die
Unregierbarkeit eines Bundeslandes
sozusagen im Alleingang auflösen wird
und sich dort dann wieder so alte
gewohnte Mehrheiten finden ich glaube
das ist ja das das mag vielleicht hier
und dann Wunschtraum sein aber
die die Lage wird auch nach der Wahl ob
mit oder obwohl ohne Wagen nicht Partei
gerade in Thüringen extrem schwierig
sein wird eine Koalition zu bilden was
wird die Wagenknecht Partei sein eine
AFD mit demokratische Programm
also es gibt viele Überschneidungen das
eine ist das habe ich schon angesprochen
die Kritik an der an den
Waffenlieferungen die Kritik an der an
der embargung Politik gegenüber Russland
diese Nähe ist offenkundig
es ist auch die Kritik an einer
bestimmten Politik die im linksliberalen
großstadtmilieu getrieben wird da finden
sich auch Überschneidung das ist ja eine
ihre hauptmotivpunkte wenn man ihr Buch
liest dass sie sagt die Linksparteien
ihre alten Form hat sich von diesem
Milieus entfernt wir haben diese Leute
nicht mehr wahrgenommen das sind die
Leute die mit kleinen Einkommen mit
mieten mit Inflation mit Energiepreisen
zu tun haben
die haben wir vergessen und wir die
Linkspartei hat sich in den Großstädten
wie Bremen oder in Berlin auch ein
Milieu konzentriert um das auch die
Grünen ähm Ringen also
Klimaschutz Klimafragen die Fragen der
Identität also welcher sexuellen Neigung
fühle ich mich zugehörig die dieses
Milieu bedienen und sie hat ja da ein
ganz klaren Trendstück gesagt sehr diese
Leute die wir früher an der Linkspartei
hatten die müssen wir wieder
zurückgewinnen und das ist ja auch ein
Milieu was die AFD anspricht und zwar
insbesondere im Osten und ich glaube
wenn diese Partei von Frau Wagen kenne
ich einen Aufschlag machen wird dann
wird es im Osten sein und wenn ich eine
Sache noch ergänzen darf Thüringen finde
ich deswegen so interessant auch gerade
in der russlandfrage weil Bodo Ramelow
wie ich finde zu Recht ja auch sehr
scharf den Angriffskrieg Russland gegen
die Ukraine kritisiert hat und es gibt
einen anderen Ministerpräsidenten einer
ganz anderen Partei das ist in Sachsen
Herr Kretschmer der auf einer Welle
reitet ähnlich wie die AFD die Politik
der jetzigen Bundesregierung auch und
auch Teil seiner CDU zu kritisieren was
Russland Politik angeht und er fährt
damit dass zeigen uns die Umfragen
relativ gut weil wo du Ramelow ist es im
Grunde genommen der Punkt gewesen wo
auch sein Abschwung eingesetzt hat und
das ist ja die große Gefahr es ist nicht
nur die Gefahr die im entsteht durch
diese Wagenknecht Partei sollte sie
überhaupt in Thüringen antreten sondern
auch den Kurs den er gefahren hat die
ehrenwert ist der ihm aber in diesem
Milieu sie haben es angesprochen in
Ostdeutschland gerade dort in Thüringen
jetzt große Probleme macht neben vielen
anderen die es vielleicht auch anderen
Seiten an seiner Koalition zu
kritisieren gibt aber das ist glaube ich
ein sehr wichtiger Punkt
das heißt also die AFD entrüm die
Wagenknecht Partei ähnlich wie die AFD
die möglicherweise den Erfolg in
Ostdeutschland sucht aber da sie auch
eine neue Partei ist ist dieser Erfolg
nicht unbedingt garantiert auch wenn Sie
sich jetzt versucht zu profilieren also
eine linke Wirtschaftspolitik und eine
konservative Gesellschaftspolitik gerade
war ja schon die Frage geht das
überhaupt zusammen offensichtlich dass
diese Erwartungen Erwartungshaltung vor
allen Dingen in den östlichen
Bundesländern wo die AFD bisher stark
war also die Frage noch mal ist das
tatsächlich ein
erfolgsversprechendes Modell selbst wenn
es in der politikwissenschaftlichen
Theorie ganz offensichtlich solche Links
konservativen nicht so häufig gibt und
die mehr gewünscht werden ja genau also
erstmal ist es ein bisschen
intellektuell schwer zu verstehen dass
eine linke eben konservativ ist und
nicht progressiv und auch das ganze
Thema internationaler Solidarität was
für meine Begriffe zum Link sein dazu
gehört damit ja die Frage gestellt wird
und man platt gesagt was Wagenknecht ja
tut Flüchtlinge gegen Arbeiter ausspielt
und ich kann mir nicht vorstellen dass
das ein langfristig tragfähiges Konzept
ist ja es gibt ein Milieu das natürlich
diese Partei wählen könnte was ich
vielleicht auch aus den ehemaligen
corona-impfgegnern speist jetzt
übergegangen ist in ein eben ja Waffen
waffenlieferungs kritisches Milieu und
wo man vielleicht sagt ja die AFD hat da
und da einen Punkt aber ich bin mir zu
gut um eben diese in Teilen
rechtsextreme Partei zu wählen das mag
sein aber insgesamt finde ich ist doch
das Risiko so groß dass wir uns das doch
wirklich nicht wünschen können es kann
doch genauso gut sein dass ich die Linke
vollkommen zerlegt ist keine linke
Opposition mehr gibt nur die AFD
triumphiert und sich Populisten vom
linken und rechten Rand gegenseitig
befeuern ein Klima das Populismus ein
vergiftetes Klima schaffen indem seriöse
Politiker die nicht das Blaue vom Himmel
versprechen sondern an Lösungen arbeiten
in die da mit ihrer gemäßigten Stimme
gar nicht mehr durchdringen aber ich
glaube es ist ja nicht eine Frage dass
was wir uns wünschen sondern das ist
glaube ich die Frage warum entstehen
Parteien in bestimmten Zeiten also wir
haben ja die Gründung der AFD die ja
auch nicht vom Himmel gefallen ist
sondern wir hatten vor ein Euro-Krise
dann gab es diese Euro kritische Partei
die sich dann 2015/2016 mit der großen
Flüchtlingsbewegung nach Deutschland
immer mehr in eine
antimigrationspartei gewandelt hat und
die nutzen heute ja zum Teil
rechtsextreme offen völkisch ist
insbesondere in Thüringen wo er die
gesamte Landesverband vom
Verfassungsschutz als
rechtsextremistisch eingestuft worden
ist und wir müssen uns doch eigentlich
fragen warum kann warum reden wir heute
in dieser Sendung über die Möglichkeit
einer Partei die sich wie auch immer wir
sie nennen aber dieser Wagenknecht
Partei bilden kann es gibt doch
offensichtlich eine Lücke die sie
besetzen kann denn sonst hätten wir ja
auch nicht diese Umfrageergebnisse die
darauf hindeuten dass sie eine Chance
hat
die Frage ist in der Tat ob sie das
langfristig ausfüllen kann aber nehmen
wir das Beispiel Migrationspolitik ihre
Kritik ist ja dass wir nicht eine
Politik der offenen Grenzen machen
können wie sie ja einen teilen die
Linkspartei propagiert sie hat ja jetzt
mit der Frau Rakete sogar eine
Kandidatin für die Europaliste
vorgeschlagen die ja eine aktive
Flüchtlingshelferin war bzw noch ist
also ein konträres und Konzept es gibt
zwei Konzepte in der in der Linkspartei
das war wirklich top Konzept gegen das
andere Konzept die kommen einfach nicht
mehr zusammen und deswegen glaube ich
ist diese Spaltung die auch getrieben
ist von erheblichen persönlichen
Animositäten einfach unabwendbar und in
der Migrationspolitik haben wir ja
gesehen wenn wir den Blick zum Beispiel
werfen nach Dänemark die
Sozialdemokratie Dänemarks hat ja mit
einer ganz restriktiven
Migrationspolitik ist wieder geschafft
die Rechtspopulisten in Dänemark
zurückzudrängen und alte Milieus wieder
an sich zu binden also es ist überhaupt
nicht gesagt dass Konservative Elemente
und linke Politik Sozialpolitik nicht
zusammen gehen können jetzt bekommt ja
die AFD offensichtlich da schon
fraxhausen wegen dieser Absichten die
ko-vorsitzender der Partei alles Weidel
hat am Sonntag im ARD sommerinterview
gesagt die Gründung von Sahra
Wagenknecht die würde das
regierungskritische Lager spalten damit
solle die AFD von einer
Regierungsbeteiligung abgehalten werden
Wagenknecht sei eine willige
Erfüllungsgehilfin von Ampel und CDU
noch mal schnell ist die welche
Möglichkeiten hat Sahra Wagenknecht als
Alternative zur Alternative für
Deutschland erfolgt zu haben naja nehmen
wir das Beispiel der Waffenlieferung
oder der Frage des Verhaltens in Bezug
auf den Krieg in der Ukraine was wählt
denn jemand der gegenwaffenlieferung ist
und wie gesagt nicht jetzt darum es geht
jetzt nicht darum was wir uns wünschen
oder so was was gibt es für ein Angebot
für den im Moment gibt es wer für
denjenigen der gegen Waffenlieferung ist
im Grunde genommen nur die Option die
AFD zu wählen so da ist eine Lücke da
ist eine Lücke die sie doch durchaus
viel äh fühlen könnte weil das natürlich
auch beispielsweise Friedens bewegte
vielleicht auch ehemalige grünanhänger
Anhängerinnen gibt die das gar nicht mal
so sehen wie das sage ich mal ein
Großteil der Parteien sieht auch ein
Großteil der in in Medien wiedergegeben
in Meinungen insofern tritt und für die
wäre das beispielsweise dann
alternatives Angebot wobei sich wiederum
die Frage stellt wie nachhaltig ist es
dann
und insbesondere auch glaube ich wird
davon abhängen wie dieser Krieg weiter
verläuft und inwieweit er Thema ist im
Moment ist es ja eine Phase der
Gewöhnung da tobt jetzt Tausende von
Kilometern entfernt hier
ein Krieg wir sehen aber auch keine
großen Friedensdemos im Moment oder so
also im Moment würde sie so weit weg
also Luft
die meisten anderen Kriege der
Vergangenheit waren aber in Bewusstsein
ist im Moment durchaus weiter weg außer
das noch vor einigen Monaten war wenn er
wieder zurückkommt in das Bewusstsein in
den nächsten Monaten wenn beispielsweise
die ukraineische Offensive weiterhin
nicht vorankommt wenn dieser Krieg der
sozusagen dort ins Stocken gerät wenn
die Diskussion der Waffenlieferungen
auch vielleicht Bezug auf Energiepreise
wieder hoch kocht dann kann das
natürlich auf die Wasser auf die Mühlen
von Sauberkeit nicht sein es ist
mehrfach der Begriff Fortschritt hier
gefallen was müssen vielleicht neu
definieren
äh Fortschritt war ja bisher immer mehr
Liberalität mehr Selbstbestimmung
anstatt einer
patriarchalischen Gesellschaft die in
Deutschland noch gar nicht so lange
zurückliegt jeder kann so leben wie er
möchte Gendern ist etwas was als moderne
als moderne
sprachbegabt Begabungen moderne
Sprachkompetenz gilt müssen wir da und
es war halt immer als links links war
immer fortschrittlich damit können die
Linkspartei heute immer noch Wahlkämpfe
bestreiten müssen wir diesen Fortschritt
Begriffen neu definieren
also in der Politikwissenschaft wird
schon ganz lange Links nicht als das was
sie vorhin gesagt haben bezeichnet
sondern es wird da schon also wirklich
relativ lange unterscheiden zwischen
zwei Dimensionen die so zu ökonomische
die soziokulturelle und das eine ist
eben konservativ das haben sie ja gerade
erläutert aber das Bewusstsein ist
eigentlich schon lange da dass man da
unterscheiden muss und die Gesellschaft
in Europa unterscheiden sich auch wieder
so die Wählerschaft und Sympathisanten
jeweils verteilt sind das ist also gar
nicht neu es ist auch überhaupt gar
nicht neu das konservativ das links
konservativ sein kann spätestens seit
1989 das wurde nur oft überhaupt gar
nicht wahrgenommen weil die linken
Parteien in Osteuropa ja natürlich alle
konservativ sind es gab ja vorher ein
System das ein anderes Modell verfolgt
hat also diese Begriffe von konservativ
und progressiv die passen sowieso und
vielerlei Hinsicht überhaupt gar nicht
da für die Realität gut einzufangen und
jetzt haben wir eben noch so quer zu
diesem ökonomisch und kulturell ja diese
Dimension von
riesen Russland Krieg das passt nicht da
rein das ist im Grunde eine dritte
konfliktdimension die relativ stark ist
in der Gesellschaft aber aus meiner
Sicht eher zwischen Ost und West
tatsächlich mal geht ist er nicht bei
allen Themen so und deshalb ist es
schwer zu prognostizieren
die da die Unterstützung für so eine
Partei sein wird und man muss sehr genau
schauen was steht dann nachher im
Programm es kann nicht die Linie nur von
Sahra Wagenknecht persönlich sein denn
damit wird sie aus meiner Sicht
längerfristig in
Westdeutschland nicht unbedingt
verfangen darf ich noch eine Sache
es wurde ja oft argumentiert wir wollen
eigentlich zurück zu den stabilen
Verhältnissen der 80er Jahre da ging das
ja auch das war ja auch Demokratie ja
wir zurück zur ökonomischen Vernunft
heißt es jetzt weil sie diesen bei allem
was man so hört zu Wagenknecht aber man
muss ja doch sagen dass die Verhältnisse
sich sehr verändert haben ob das nun die
Europa politische Einbindung ist ob das
da asylartikel ist im Grundgesetz seit
den 90er Jahren da kommt man ja gar
nicht ohne große Unterstützung hin und
dann müssen muss man eine Wagenknecht
sofort fragen wie halten Sie es mit der
AFD wie wollen Sie denn zwei Drittel
Mehrheiten organisieren um das
Grundgesetz zu ändern das sind ja ganz
praktische Fragen um überhaupt
irgendwelche Träume verwirklichen zu
können
ja also das muss man sie fragen weil wir
haben jetzt ja schon öfter Thüringen
erwähnt da gibt es ja einen Mann namens
Möller enger Vertrauter von höcke und
der hat anders als Weidel geredet der
freut sich schon auf eine Wagenknecht
Partei und sagt ja super dann können wir
eine Koalition bilden gegen das wie es
immer bei der AFD heißt Kartell der
Altparteien also da wird mir Angst und
Bange ehrlich gesagt wenn ich das höre
und die Frage ist immer und die stellt
sich übrigens auch die CDU ähm holt man
AFD wieder zurück oder rennt man ihn
nach und bei Wagenknecht habe ich schon
immer wieder stark das Gefühl dass sie
ihn nachdenkt mit ihrem geredet davon
also dass irgendwie der Staat uns
vorschreibe wie wir zu essen zu reden
hätten das ist einfach vollkommener
Quatsch diese Verbote von denen sie da
spricht die gibt es nicht und auch zum
Thema Russland wenn sie da eine Täter
Opfer Umkehr betreibt indem sie sagt
also wir hätten einen Wirtschaftskrieg
gegen Russland vom Zaun gebrochen dann
ist es einfach perfide und zynisch und
das finde ich muss man auch immer wieder
klar machen wenn man von einer
Wagenknecht Partei redet in dem Fall in
diesem Fall soll ausnahmsweise die Kopie
besser sein als das Original genau was
ja schon oft nicht aufgegangen ist
sondern sich bewiesen hat das immer das
Original gewählt wird auch wenn
CDU-Vertreter das probiert haben zum
Beispiel wenn ich eine Sache sagen darf
was die Betrachtung der AFD angeht ist
eine Partei mit der ich mich auch seit
Jahren beschäftige und mir ja viel auf
bei diesem Sommer Interview von Frau
Weidel dass sie bei aller Kritik an Frau
Wagenknecht doch viel Sympathie auch hat
erkennen lassen sie hat gesagt sie
wünscht dir alles Gute und sie hat das
ja sehr moderat vorgetragen und es gibt
auch außerhalb des AFD Milieus
beispielsweise bei dem höcke
Förderer und Freund Gott Götz Kubitschek
gibt es Stimmen die sagen die Frau
Wagenknecht dürfen keinesfalls schaffen
angreifen wir dürfen also nicht sein die
uns ja torischen
Wahlkampf gegen sie führen etwa als
ehemaliges Mitglied der Kommunistischen
Plattform der
von PDS das zeigt ja man kämpft dort im
Osten zumal um dasselbe Milieu und da
gibt es also eine gewisse Rücksichtnahme
und Sie haben ja den Herrn Möller
genannt der sich schon darauf freut dann
sogenannte Bündnisse mit dieser Partei
dann durchzuführen das wird man
abzusehen haben das ist für mich ist der
eine Unterscheidungspunkt und das ist
die Frage wie geht sie in der
Migrationsfrage um also es gibt in der
AFD diesen in Teilen der Partei
völkischen Ansatz wird sich der
wiederfinden im linken Gewand bei der
Wagenknecht Partei da kann ich ehrlich
gesagt auch keine Garantie dafür abgeben
dass das nicht so sein wird aber im
Moment ist das was Frau Wagenknecht sagt
in Migrationsfragen unterscheidet sich
ja nicht so sehr von dem was auch in
anderen Parteien diskutiert wird über
die Frage stärkerer Grenzkontrolle wie
wie können wir den Zustrom runterfahren
das das ist glaube ich der eine Punkt
der sie von der AFD sozusagen trennt man
wird aber dann wenn sich tatsächlich
diese Partei etablieren sollte im Osten
dann sehen wie geht es ganz unten in den
kommunalen in den Landesparlamenten mit
ihr weiter und das ist eine offene Frage
da wir haben jetzt schon mehrfach gehört
dass
was das für die bisherige politische
Heimat von Sarah Wagenknecht bedeutet
die Linke die maximal haben sie es
glaube ich gesagt demoliert werden soll
also Partei auf offener Bühne gemäuchelt
wird was macht das jetzt mit der Partei
DIE LINKE liefert sich sozusagen auch
noch die Munition mit der Sahra
Wagenknecht dann auf sie ballern kann
wie ist dieses die ganze Strategie der
der Linken zu sehen was bedeutet das
dann tatsächlich wenn Sie Ernst macht ja
ich würde mal sagen die Linke ist schon
so gut wie maximal demoliert sie ist bei
unter 5% gelandet bei den letzten Wahlen
sie hat auf Kunden von ein paar tausend
Stimmen und einem direkt man darf noch
gerade so den Einzug in den Bundestag
geschafft als also als Fraktion der ist
aber auch immer noch fragil es gibt da
gewisse noch gerichtliche Entscheidungen
hinsichtlich der Wiederholungen Berlin
also das ich also wie viel tiefer soll
es denn noch gehen sozusagen die Linke
ist ohne Erfolg und auch die neue
Parteiführung hat kein Erfolg und
natürlich ist ein Grund dafür dass sich
dort zwei Lager miteinander wir kriegen
und das für Außenstehende immer
schwieriger wird nachzuvollziehen was
das eigentlich soll oder warum sie
dieser Partei eigentlich die Stimme
geben soll ich glaube das ist durchaus
für sozusagen diese linke nee eine
Option geben kann weil anschließen dann
das was sie gerade gesagt haben ganz
interessantes Interview von äh Minecraft
for total
migrationsforscherin hier in Berlin
durchaus ja auch eine prominente Stimme
hat für uns der Zeitung vor kurzem
gesagt er na ja die Wagenknecht Partei
das ist so eigentlich der einzige Game
changer den es auch geben kann um die
AFD nächstes Jahr zu dezimieren hat
gesagt nicht ist keine intrinsische
Rassistin sondern könnte dort nicht
Milieu binden was durchaus eben nicht
dieses diesen völkischen weg oder so ist
mein Freund
so in etwa aber sie hat noch was
interessantes gesagt darum komme ich
drauf sie hat gesagt naja für die Linke
als solche gibt es natürlich durchaus
ein Potenzial als beispielsweise Post
migrantische Partei wir haben viele
Migrantinnen und Migranten oder Menschen
mit Migrationsgeschichte in Deutschland
die nicht wählen die nicht in der
Demokratie in irgendeiner Weise
vertreten sind können schon diese
Position womöglich aber vielleicht
geht's reden wir da ja dann wieder über
Einkommens äh und Klassenzugehörigkeit
vielleicht gibt's ja auch einen
Migranten die bei den Grünen nicht so
vertreten sind und natürlich ist dieser
Ansatz mit Gerhard Trabert dem anderen
Kandidaten für das Europaparlament der
vorgesehen ist und ähm Carola Rakete
durchaus interessanter das ist jetzt der
Versuch der sogenannten bewegungslinken
genau auch dieses Milieu zu mobilisieren
und das ist jetzt aus Sicht der
Parteiführung meiner Meinung nach keinen
schlechte Entscheidung fest steht nur
dass im Moment in der Partei offenbar
niemand Verantwortung übernehmen will es
werden zwei Fraktionsvorsitzende im
Bundestag gesucht der bisherige
Fraktionsvorsitzende die immer Bart ich
werde dafür kämpfen dass die Fraktion
Fraktion bleibt da hat er sich auch was
vorgenommen denn würden glaube ich drei
gehen aus der Fraktion dann würde der
Fraktionsstatus und verloren gehen zehn
etwa rechnet man könnten mit Sahra Wagen
nicht die Fraktion verlassen dann ist es
nur noch eine Gruppe
nur zwei Abgeordnete der
damaligen noch PDS glaube ich
weil sie die 5% würde nicht geschafft
haben und nur zwei Direktmandate
bekommen haben all das sind ja keine
guten Zukunftsperspektiven für die Linke
man muss jetzt natürlich kurzfristige
und langfristige Perspektiven noch mal
unterscheiden man hat auch bei anderen
Parteien schon gedacht die sind jetzt
weg vom Fenster die Zeit ist vorbei man
hat lange Zeit diskutiert gibt braucht
es überhaupt noch den Liberalismus wir
sind alle so liberal braucht überhaupt
noch liberale Parteien dann gab es die
Diskussion braucht man überhaupt
sozialdemokratische Parteien und so
weiter also es kann sein das Parteien
vorübergehend auch weg sind gar nicht
stark sind und sich dann wieder
berappeln das kann sein das wissen wir
heute noch nicht aber kurzfristig sehe
ich jetzt auch keine rosige Zukunft für
die sind in Deutschland auf eine Partei
wie die Linke 40 oder würde das
irgendwas ins Rutschen bringen also ich
glaube wir könnten nicht darauf
verzichten ich ähm ich habe das auch
kurz in einem Kommentar geschrieben und
kam gleich böse Briefe wie jetzt schon
die Fazit für eine Christiane und
Christian Lindner sagte ist ja auch im
Notfall könnte man noch die Linke wählen
um und sagt meinte eben man muss nicht
die AFD wählen und das würde ich unter
erreichen denn natürlich muss es wenn
das eine ampelregierung gibt irgendwie
auch eine Opposition von Links geben
denn sonst überlässt man das Feld ja
vollkommen der AFD und insofern würde
ich auch Ihnen widersprechen Herr
professional das ist nicht tiefer
Bergabgehen kann im Moment gibt es ja
noch eine Fraktion Die Linke und dieser
Fraktionsstatus wäre dann natürlich
schnell dahin und dann hätte man keine
Opposition mehr im Bundestag keine linke
die Linke hat ja auch gezeigt in ihrer
Geschichte als zunächst als PDF
nachfolgerpartei dann der SED der
früheren Staatspartei der DDR dass sie
eine integrative Leistung vollbracht hat
das sehen wir an Bodo ramelo der
Ministerpräsident ist in Thüringen wir
haben es gesehen an einer rot-roten
Koalition damals in Berlin unter Klaus
Wowereit wir sehen es immer noch an
einer rot rot gelben grünen Koalition in
Bremen ähm dass diese Partei durchaus
integrative
Kraft hat
nur im Osten hat sie ja doch tendenziell
stärker verloren da können auch diese
relativ guten Ergebnisse bei der letzten
Abgeordneten mal in Berlin nicht darüber
hinwegtäuschen wo die Linke ja noch gute
rausgekommen ist obwohl sie in der
Opposition landete und in Bremen ist sie
durch die Arbeit der Senatoren durch
eine starke Konzentration auf
Sozialpolitik wieder in die Regierung
gekommen das zeigt sich also durchaus
dass der reformerische Flügel bei den
Linken da ein Ansatz hat
der ist deplaziert also in Bremen würde
ich sagen hat sich das nicht so erwiesen
weil man doch sich dort sehr stark auf
auf das Milieu der Sozialpolitik
konzentriert hat also ein klassisches
Thema aufgegriffen hat eigentlich ganz
im Sinne von Sarah Wagenknecht in Berlin
würde ich sagen in dieser diversen Stadt
ist es noch mal anders aber wenn wir
rausgehen aus Berlin schon nach
Brandenburg dort ist die Links Partei
schon nicht mehr das was sie vor 10 15
Jahren war und sie ist es auch nicht
mehr in Mecklenburg-Vorpommern sie ist
es auch nicht mehr den anderen
ostdeutschen Ländern außer in Thüringen
und selbst da schwächelt sie ja doch
geworden kommt ja immer wieder sie wäre
für das wo also die Linke für das woke
waren
für linke Studenten Zirkel und jetzt mit
Carola Rakete eine Flüchtlingshelferin
in der Spitzenkandidatur für die Wahl
zum Europäischen Parlament wie gesagt
Lifestyle linke würde man sich in Berlin
auch überlegen ob Gesine Lodge und Petra
Pau zum Beispiel diesen Profil so
wirklich entsprechend wirken ist das ein
ungerechtfertigter Vorwurf das ist
sicherlich ein in vielfacher Hinsicht
immer wieder auch überspitzter Vorwurf
und zugespitzter Vorwurf der
dann auch außer Acht lässt das ist ja
durchaus auch Studierende gibt die sich
in ihren Uni Städten keine Wohnung
leisten können aufgrund der Wohnungsnot
und durchaus empfänglich sind für
Programmatiken wie die der Linken aber
man muss hier nur den letzten verteiltag
anschauen oder auch lesen was Gregor
Gisi jetzt sagt das ist ja keiner der
der Polemiken gegen Laster linke
verdächtig ist aber auch er hat gesagt
Leute
binneni oder Sternchen das ist nicht die
Frage die unsere Wählerinnen und Wähler
mehrheitlich interessiert wir müssen für
vor einem soziale Fragen streiten also
ich glaube die wenn man das Buch ich
möchte am allermeisten ja das ist nicht
mein Eindruck sie redet meinem Eindruck
nach am allermeisten eigentlich schon
über soziale Themen sie wird nur sehr
gern darauf angesprochen und das was sie
dazu sagt wird im Grunde genommen dazu
dann verarbeitet wenn man sich ihr Buch
anliest dann wenn man sich hier Buch
durchliest dann findet man dort ganz
viel im Grunde genommen ist es eine
Popularisierung und polemisierung von
dem was Andreas reckwitz in seinen
Büchern schreibt singularisierte
Gesellschaft da ist ganz ähnliches ist
auch eine der meisten zentiertesten
Werke und man muss ja noch mal sagen die
Leute die sich jahrelang an ihr und an
dieser Kritik aber abgearbeitet haben
beispielsweise in der Linksfraktion im
Bundestag bei den hatte man schon über
die Jahre hinweg den Eindruck dass es
eigentlich kein wichtigeres Ziel gibt es
daran wirklich Lust zu werden jetzt
stehen Sie kurz vor dem Ziel jetzt
treten die beiden Fraktionsvorsitzenden
zurück und keiner ist anscheinend
irgendwie bereit sich jetzt davon
hinzustellen und den Kameras in diesem
Buch die selbstgerechten gerechnet sie
ja mit der Identitätspolitik der Linken
ab ähm ist das Ausdruck eines Kultur
Kampfes in Deutschland wo Sarah
Wagenknecht und die ihren mit der AFD
auf der einen Seite sind die anderen
Parteien auf der anderen
also ich glaube die also es gibt ja
Umfrageergebnisse dazu auch da sind
natürlich immer die Antwortmöglichkeiten
vorgegeben das ist schwierig dann die
Interpretation aber ich glaube das
mittlerweile die der Großteil der
Gesellschaft eigentlich relativ
entspannt mit diesen Themen umgeht und
sich eigentlich eher da denkt haben wir
nicht andere Themen über die wir
sprechen müssen insofern taugt das
glaube ich nicht so wirklich für die
Mobilisierung der Mehrheit der
Gesellschaft Teile schon und ich glaube
nicht dass man sich jetzt doch
wahnsinnig lange mit diesem Thema groß
beschäftigen kann das ist irgendwie auch
jetzt vom Tisch habe ich den Eindruck
man braucht den neuen Themen und ich
glaube dass der Russland viel mehr zählt
oder auch die Frage
Spitzensteuersatz und solche Dinge also
so handfeste Themen auch
Gesundheitsversorgung und und andere
Dinge die man auf der Agenda stehen ob
das immer die Themen sind die dann
wirklich in der Europawahl gut
aufgehoben sind oder in Landtagswahlen
ähm also das das frage ich mich weil es
werden ja die ersten Wahlen sein wo sich
diese Parteien muss und wo nach dann
alle sie bewerten werden ob sie jetzt
erfolgreich ist oder nicht aber
eigentlich sind die Themen ja Bundes
politische Themen und Europa politisch
aber anders konturiert ich sehe noch
nicht dass man im Grunde als
Wählerschaft sozusagen da jetzt an der
richtigen Stelle und zum richtigen
Zeitpunkt Sympathie für so ein Projekt
ausdrückt also es bringt dann nicht so
viel
läuft ja Gefahr als Tiger zu springen
und als Bettvorleger zu landen sich
genau macht sie ernst oder nicht wir das
ist ja auch Thema der Sendung hier sieht
er selbst ja einiges wörtlich dazu
beigesteuert in den letzten Tagen in
Interviews Strukturen aufbauen sagt sie
Organisation Landesverbände das werde
ich nicht leisten können klassische
Partei Arbeit ist ihr zu viel dafür
hätte sie jedoch Freunde in der Linken
die ihr jetzt folgen werden solche
Bekenntnisse zu im Vorfeld der Gründung
einer Partei was signalisieren die
eigentlich sozusagen eine
ehrliche Selbsteinschätzung oder eher
ein Hinweis darauf also ich glaube ich
mag es doch nicht also insofern ehrlich
als dass sie ja offen zugibt dass sie
schon mal gescheitert ist mit der
Bewegung aufstehen und insofern daraus
für sich den Schluss gezogen hat dass
das nicht ihr Ding ist aber ähm na ja
wenn sie sagt gut also die die Kerne
Arbeit das sollen andere machen ich kann
dann die Position nach außen vertreten
also im Klartext ich kann dann bequem
vom Talkshow Sessel aus kommentieren was
die anderen da aufbauen also ich finde
das irgendwie das entspricht doch
eigentlich einer lifestyling also für
mich ist Wagenknecht da die größte
Lifestyle linke die eben Youtube
Sendungen macht und da wie eine
influencerin agiert aber im Bundestag
nie zu sehen ist keine Facharbeit in den
Ausschüssen macht sondern sich dafür zu
gut ist und das würde mich als
möglicher Wähler als solchen Partei
schon ins Grübeln bringen das heißt wen
braucht sie denn eigentlich Kulis
Drohnen Leute die völlig entsagen mit
asketischen Fähigkeiten die nichts für
sich wollen und alles für Sarah gibt es
solche ein arbeitsplatzprofil noch in
der Republik naja also erstmal muss man
sagen das was sie da jetzt gesagt ist ja
nicht neu das hat sie schon seit Jahren
sie erklärt seit Jahren eigentlich seit
dem Ende ihrer Zeit als
Fraktionsvorsitzende dass sie gewisse
Schwächen hat und und das eigentlich
doch eine angenehme Art von Ehrlichkeit
das Politikerin dazu geschehen dass zum
Beispiel die kernarbeit der
Mehrheitsbeschaffung oder so weiter
nicht
das eigene Anliegen ist das ist aber
letztlich für die Frage kommt es zur
Verteidigung oder nicht die
entscheidende Frage weil der Deal ist ja
offensichtlich der dass sie ein Team hat
aus Leuten das gerade an den rechtlichen
Voraussetzungen an der Organisation und
in einem arbeitet und ich denke mal
irgendwann jetzt eben in den nächsten
Monaten wird dann die Frage die der
Zeitpunkt des Hoppe oder Tops sein dann
wird ihr vorgelegt was sozusagen da
jetzt vorbereitet wurde dann wird sie
den Daumen heben oder denken und in
diesem Kreis denke ich mal sind durchaus
ist durchaus der ein oder andere dabei
der schon den Fusionsprozess zwischen
der ESG und PS mitgemacht hat also eine
gewisse Erfahrung bei solchen Fragen
mitbringt und es sind glaube ich doch
auch die der ein oder andere junge dabei
der wahnsinnig viel Frustration aus den
äh aus den vergangenen Jahren und der
Fraktion und der Partei Arbeit zieht und
irgendwie jetzt vielleicht irgendwie die
die Chance sieht das doch noch mal
politisch was neues startet
wie lang ist denn wie lange hat sie noch
Zeit wie groß ist das Zeitfenster lang
die Europawahl ist definitiv der Termin
der am Horizon politischen Businessplan
oder wird sie die Finger davon lassen
also ich glaube das sie wird noch die
die Hessen und die Bayernwahl sich
angucken und danach muss sie im im
Verlaufe des Spätherbstes Winters eine
Entscheidung treffen denn äh zur
Europawahl hat sie das in den Vorteil es
gibt ja nicht die 5% Klausel also sie
kommt da relativ selbst mit 2 %
rein und dann bekommen sie glaube ich
auch 0,5% sogar Rückerstattung das heißt
es gibt noch einen finanziellen Vorteil
also es würde sich ohnehin lohnen das in
Angriff zu nehmen und dann muss sie
natürlich die nächste Frage entscheiden
treten wir in den ostdeutschen
Bundesländern an in den nächsten Jahr
Landtagswahlen anstehen also Thüringen
und Sachsen und ähm ja das alles muss
sie in sehr kurzer Zeit jetzt
entscheiden und ähm sie haben das
angesprochen sie sie selber ist nicht in
der oder sagt selber sie ist nicht in
der Lage organisatorischen Apparat zu
führen sie braucht also wirklich
entscheidende Leute und das ist für mich
die spannende Frage hat sie die wirklich
in ihrem Umfeld von den Leuten die man
ja kennt die auch im Bundestag sind und
die zu ihr gezielt sind das sind alles
sehr laute Leute die sind so ähnlich
strukturiert wie sie aber sind die
wirklich in der Lage eine Partei zu
führen und auch eine Partei
zusammenzuhalten oder werden da nicht
dann doch wieder neue Fliehkräfte
ausgelöst also
die Entwicklung ich sag mal wenn man es
parallel nimmt mit der AFD ein Mann wie
gauland von dem wusste man auch dass er
sehr gut war Dinge zu delegieren als er
noch er ist ja heute Ehrenvorsitzender
der Partei und Fraktion früher war aber
als Parteivorsitzender musste er in die
Bitte und dann musste er dort auch die
Partei organisieren hat das aber
geschickterweise immer auch durch andere
machen lassen also es ist bei der AFD
gelungen das zu stabilisieren und die
Frage ist ob ihr das gelingt wir haben
leider nur noch 30 Sekunden machen sie
Standpunkt heute bewegen sich die feste
müssen
leg mich nicht fest also wenn sie es
nicht macht dann hat sie wirklich ein
Jahr lang ihre Partei und das Land in
Atem gehalten um dann am Ende zu sagen
nee sorry ich habe jetzt zwar alles
zerstört was da ist aber kann nichts
Neues anbieten also das wäre dann ihre
Hinterlassenschaft gut das Warten wir in
aller Ruhe ab vielen Dank weil die ja
gestern Lorenz Sebastian Puschner und
Severin weiland Liebe ZuschauerInnen
liebe Zuschauer morgen in der Phönix
Runde lege Rede Rede zur Lage der EU was
bedeuten von der lines Vorschläge
aktuell ist bei Phoenix der Tag mit
Thomas Bade darin heute Abend schon
Europa nämlich die Berichterstattung aus
der Sitzungswoche des Europäischen
Parlaments das wird morgen also in der
Rede von Ursula von der Leyen dann
hinein München bleiben Sie bei uns
[Musik]